i feel like this is the inauguration for
the new mayor of ponderosa i'm so
excited to talk to you today
how are you doing
i'm good i'm good number one like queen
i'm super excited to talk to you
okay i think i am talking to royalty um
but no i'm good i'm good i'm excited um
it's been a great season so far and so
like i'm just excited to talk about it
amazing i mean if i'm royalty you are
the mayor now you get to go to ponderosa
and be the first member of the jury so
i've got to ask when you were going into
tribal council how did you think
everybody was going to vote
so like i thought i was going to get
some votes i thought romeo was going to
go i thought that perhaps like marion
might get a couple votes but i
ultimately thought that romeo was gonna
go i think
like that day at camp um we saw
a lot of kind of chaos ensue around
romeo and i was like let me just step
out the way so this train doesn't hit me
and just hit someone else and so i think
that that was kind of like what my
thought process was
um in retrospect i wish i played my shot
in the dark but you know hindsight's 20
20.
yeah i wanted to ask did you ever
consider playing your shot in the dark
or were you so confident that this train
was going to hit romeo not actually but
you know the figurative the figurative
train honestly erica like
low-key i forgot that i had it like
honestly like there's so much going on
in the game and then you have your shot
in the dark like you were given like at
the start and you're like
like i don't know i kind of it kind of
like was in the back of my mind and so i
didn't really think that i was in that
much of like a position that i needed to
like seriously consider it like i knew
that i was on the outs i knew that
people were kind of like ostracizing me
um but i didn't know that the bullseye
was right on my head because i was still
having conversations and we don't see
this but i'm still having conversations
with like omar and with lindsay and like
the folks around at camp and so like
although like i knew i was on the
outside i knew i wasn't in the core
alliance it wasn't like
you are next you know
yeah so what tipped you off to make you
believe that you were on the outs and
you were at the bottom of the tribe well
i mean when we got to merge it was
pretty clear i'd like walk up to a group
and everyone just be like
you know like just walk away like not
talk to me and i'm just like
y'all can talk to me we can chat
casually you know so like it was pretty
clear and then at tribal um after i
voted for uh jonathan what we don't see
is like at tribal hi looks over to me
and he goes lydia i was trying to read
his lips so i thought his lips said
jonathan he said lydia and so when we
get back to camp i'm like why did you
wait until tribal to tell me the vote
that was a telltale sign like obviously
if someone's waiting that late in the
game to tell you a vote then you're
probably like
amongst the last to know meaning you're
on the house so i think that was also
like the telltale too it was like the
tribal before
well it seemed like especially with the
vati tribe there were always some really
eventful tribal councils i feel like you
were always part of the events that took
place so i've got to ask about some of
them like i know that there was a lot of
curiosity about your vote for mike
during the daniel tribal council so can
you share some more insight into why you
voted that way yes absolutely so like i
know a lot of people don't understand it
but like my overall like kind of
perspective is like you could cross your
fingers and hope that the person who is
clearly on the bottom doesn't play the
advantage that they literally have in
their pocket
or you can play for the worst possible
outcome and so i'm like should i should
i in a game for a million dollars a game
for my life lost my fingers and hope or
should i play like my life is on the
line i was like i'm gonna play like my
life is on the line and so in that
instance i was like i have to write down
mike's name for preservation there's a
chance that they either a
put all the votes on daniel there's a
chance that they beast with the votes
and you know it ends up in a tie and i
don't auto go home there's a chance that
lydia risked her vote at chippewa island
there's just so many permutations of
situations that you have to play in your
head and then make a decision based on
there so that's what i did
and i feel like after a tribal council
like that you always see the people
saying okay no hard feelings don't worry
it's just a game so do you think that
there was still a chance for you and
mike to work together or do you think
after that that vote really affected
your relationship
yeah i mean i think it really
affected our relationship and like i was
pretty confused for a while as to why
because i'm like listen you lied to me i
lied to you you didn't tell me you
didn't have a vote i didn't tell you i
didn't have a vote you wrote my name
down i wrote your name down but you've
done the same exact things to each other
but i was so easily able to step out of
it and be like that was gameplay and
like it's not personal and it was for
survival for you just like it was
survival for me and so like i don't have
hard feelings but for him it was
something that he emotionally held on to
and like i always like think about the
greats when i think about the greats who
play the game and like people who are
really really good
those people
might be blindsided at a tribal council
they come back to camp like good game it
might work with this person three tribal
councils down the line or two tribal
councils on the line so i'm
automatically operating like before
thinking like for operating like how the
players operate but you know um
everyone every it's an emotional game
it's a hard game there's no rights
everyone is just doing their best you
know so
yeah yeah it's hard because i feel like
as a fan of the game you go and you play
and you assume that everyone is working
from a similar place of logic but you
realize everybody has different logic so
you can try to anticipate what they're
going to do but you don't really know
and i think with that said another
moment in the game that a lot of people
are curious about is when you are at the
summit which i'm sure you've gotten a
lot of questions about so can you tell
me more about why you decided to risk
your vote in that situation
yeah so like if we just go back to like
the challenge which was grueling like i
was dead after that challenge and so
like when i had to do the the walk i
couldn't see myself like stumbling like
i'm like glazed over like
like almost delirious right and so and i
think that's by design right you push
people to their brink and then they have
to make a game-changing decision and so
uh i think like because of where i was
just like
you know mentally and physically um
when we got to the top of the summit
omar and i were chatting but we didn't
have the right kind of conversation
right so nobody see me say i can't risk
my vote because i'm going to tribal but
the other half of that conversation was
okay so here's how we're going to play
it if it hurts both of us neither of us
will take it it helps both of us both of
us will take it we never talked about it
in between like if it hurts one helps on
the other so when we get to the wheel
i'm like well omar and i just decided
that it hurt since it hurts both of us
neither of us are going to touch it i'm
going to take it and he got the the
wheel and said well chanel and i both
said it hurts both of us we're not going
to take it and so he took it so we
thought the same exact thing and like
both risked it
and uh yeah so that was the that was
probably one of my biggest mistakes of
the game and like a catalyst that kind
of kicked everything off which was not
having the right kind of conversation
with homer
it's almost like you both thought the
other was so honorable you thought so
highly of the other and then that's why
this happened exactly
so do you think that was your biggest
mistake or is there anything else that
you would have done differently
i mean
there's so much that you could do
differently right there's just so many
rows that you can take that will branch
off into different outcomes i would say
like at number one was my biggest
mistake and if that didn't happen the
game would have been completely
different um had i have i made other
mistakes in the game sure so many right
missing things but that's the thing when
you're running on no food
and like lack of sleep and the
conditions like you just kind of miss
things and so like
had i like noticed like that the
bullseye was on my head i would have
like played my shot in the dark i would
have done some things differently i
would have tried to maybe like lead with
mike like like you know i am not playing
against you like i am like chilling
right now you know so i think there are
a lot of things that you could do
differently in the game um
hindsight's 20 20.
well so as you're getting your torch
snuffed there was this great moment
where people are saying they loved you
they're saying goodbye and you just say
sure so what are you thinking at that
moment i think like the natural human
response is like number one shock
number two like you guys just voted me
out you know and took my dream away but
ultimately it's just like there's just
so many things going through your head
processing i don't remember any of it to
be quite honest like i'm just like
speechless honestly like completely
speechless
yeah well i mean it's like there's so
much so many things happening i feel
like the viewers don't understand all
the things running through your head
that you can react and honestly forget
that you've said something it's totally
normal for that to happen in survivor
yeah there's there's so much that i
block out like
i'm like wait how did this go what
happened on day two what happened on day
six like you just don't remember it's
all a blur it all like kind of just
meshes into like one big picture and
then it's even more cloudy when you
watch it back on tv because you're like
okay i remember that but i guess i don't
remember this and it kind of just
reshifts and shapes your narrative
so well now you get to eat you're on the
jury so as a jury member now what are
you looking for in the game play as you
watch it
yeah so for me like i am like a
strategist person like i am someone who
loves and respects the game so much so i
want to see like
strategy i want to see that you like
very methodically chose to make this
move because you knew that three steps
down it was gonna
impact you know x y and z and so i'm a
strategist i want to see strategists
um you know i'm a very logical person so
like i obviously naturally lean more to
like very logical uh clear like chat or
just type of people but like honestly
it's just like who is the best game like
who goes out there who gives it their
all and like ultimately like who who
played the best
so who are you rooting for to win
survivor 42
who am i rooting for you know what i'm
gonna say lindsay and the reason i'm
gonna say lindsay is because lindsay is
very like adjacent to me like very level
very even
very good social player like solid
social player like stays out of like the
crosshairs i tried to do and so i'd love
to see someone adjacent to me
uh you know take it take it home
amazing well chanel i've heard that
you're going to be serving some looks on
the jury so i cannot wait to see them i
can't wait to see the fashion and every
all the rolling eyes all the looks for
the rest of the season so i'm glad to
see you're still gonna be there but i
want to say thank you so much for
chatting and i wish you all of the best
thank you so much erica queen to queen
it's so great chatting with you love it